well good morning thanks for coming here
I believe I might have miscalculated my
audience because I'm actually going to
talk about science today sorry about
that I'll try maker you make it user
friendly but I want to talk about
innovation in the evolution of ARCA sors
there are the stars of our show today
the two major groups of living artists
ORS are the crocodilians and the birds
and I think that most of you have not
ever thought about these two creatures
being as closely related they as they
are but there are in fact one another's
nearest living relatives yeah crocodiles
and birds look very different from one
another but nonetheless they both build
nests out of vegetable matter their
embryo speak to one another in the eggs
to synchronize hatching they have
elaborate parental care the males seem
to defend territories and attract mates
and we've always known that about birds
but and always noted about crocodiles
but only recently came to appreciate
maybe if their living descendants could
do these things likewise their ancestors
could but I want to talk about the
origin of birds and how dinosaurs fit
into this scheme I know we call it the
age of mammals today and the famous age
of reptiles mural and the Peabody Museum
but in fact they're ten thousand living
dinosaurs and well we have that many
mammals I I guess we write the textbook
so gets to be the age of mammals but
there's always been more dinosaurs
around then on the mammal line and for
the last 180 million years now birds are
crowned dinosaurs think of a tree at the
top of it being the crown and the trunk
being the stem and so dinosaurs are stem
Birds of Triceratops is a stem bird
brontosaurus is
Stamford and hummingbird is a crown
dinosaur that's sort of a different way
to think about it isn't it here's our
cast of characters this is an
evolutionary tree it shows that the land
egg line that hard shelled egg right
with all the fancy membranes and the
yolk in there to feed the embryo an egg
that's made to lay on land was shared by
the common ancestor of mammals on one
hand and reptiles on the others is a
divergence that took place at least 310
million years ago the reptiles shortly
thereafter diverged into Turtles on one
hand and these things called IAPP SIDS
- arched reptiles on the other the -
arts die absence split into lizards
basically on one hand and arcus ORS on
the other and then the arcus were split
240 million years ago into the bird line
and the crocodile line now there are
only 24 living crocodilians and 10,000
living birds so but that wasn't always
the case that's the way it is today but
if you go back 240 million years it's
the opposite the world was run by
crocodilians and dinosaurs were in the
background and the crocodilians had to
suffer a huge extinction event before
the dinosaurs came to the fore
so although we put birds in their own
class and crocodilians over with the
reptiles as you can see just in the way
as humans are deeply embedded within the
Apes especially African Apes birds are
in fact way up inside of the reptiles
thank you so all the dinosaurs here
would fit along this branch of the tree
they'd all be coming off of the line
headed towards birds and that's the way
dinosaurs are stem birds babies being
there
technical scientific name this group
originated back when all the continents
were smooshed together on the planet and
this supercontinent called Pangea all
the continents were smashed together
there was a huge glacier covering all
the southern end of the continents and
this is the last time in the planets
history some 250 million years ago where
the weather was as bad as it is today
there best sit there and think about
that Minister I'm not that bad outside
but in point of fact even in an
interglacial period in which we are now
the weather is miserable and by that I
mean the difference between the
temperature in February and July right
the spread of rainfall these huge
deserts that covered much of the world's
surface across the Sahara and the like
those are completely new those are very
recent in terms of history of this
planet and it's these continental scale
glaciers that you still down in
Antarctica today right I mean oh it's
reappeared but for most of the history
of the world there is no are no ice on
the poles at the time of the age of
dinosaurs up until only maybe 40 million
years ago there was no ice on the poles
the Arctic Ocean was freshwater
saltwater down below but freshwater on
top and today it's the polar bear it's
the top predator up there but 40 million
years ago was an alligator so Ellesmere
Island 9 degrees off the North Pole had
magnolia trees giant softshell turtles
crocodilians a very different world than
we live in today but this world as you
can see is all smooshed together is very
dry there's great continental deserts
it's very much like the world of today
and being very extreme environment and
in that world the plants had died off
opening up and it gave room for being
able to evolve the capacity to breathe
while running you can see on this side
as a lizard
remember we came out of the water right
and with a body with fins on it and all
that had muscles that first contract one
side of the body and then the other
where you would get this rhythmic
swimming motion and when we emerged on
land and transformed our meaty arms into
legs but we still had a body wall
musculature and a step cycle that was
alternating and side-to-side the same
way as a lizard or a salamander or a
turtle walks today
okay turtles got a shell so it's kind of
harder to tell but that kind of
locomotion puts what's called a
constraint on the evolution of the
ability to breathe while running because
to breathe requires symmetrical motions
in the chest right but to walk
asymmetrical motions so it turns out
they couldn't breathe and run at the
same time
the lizard can run every bit as fast as
a cheetah the fastest lizard if you can
shrink the cheetah down or get the
lizard up bigger it can run just as fast
but the lizard is holding its breath
whereas the cheetah can breathe because
the cheetah has suppressed the
side-to-side motion in the body and
bends the body only up and down and we
can see that in the arcus or side they
do the same thing they go from the
sprawling posture where the legs are out
to the side to bringing their legs
beneath their body and they make various
changes to the backbone that's
suppressed side-to-side motion and
enhance up-and-down motion and you can
see here that back leg on this alligator
is perfectly vertically disposed it's
not something you'd ever see in a lizard
or a turtle
now both the mammal line and the arcus
or line did this at exactly the same
time when Pangaea is smushed together
landscapes open and lizard can run just
as fast but because they're so small
they just hold
breath till they run and get down a hole
underneath the rock it's all good but if
you're a large body can't run down a
hole you know can't run underneath the
rocks so you have to have locomotor
stamina not only run fast but continue
to run and that requires the ability to
breathe while running we know this
happened because we have fossilized
footprints and we can see the broad
spread this is a lizard today a komodo
dragon anybody know that thing but it's
one of the most upright lizards so this
is more upright than any lizard is but
you can still see how broad it is
between left and right side of the
bodies while they're walking in a
sprawling posture here is a fight a sore
that's the author of this tooth right
here
we know they were aquatic how do we know
that yes sir you can see the webs on
their toes you know at webbed feet
that's pretty good indication that it
was a swimming animal but you can see
that the footfalls are closer to the
midline and they are in any lizard when
you get into ARCA Soares proper of a
very narrow tracked upright gait again
this just is to illustrate that to walk
and breathe as a constraint called
carriers constraint David carrier the
grad student the University of Michigan
while I was postdoc in there put lizards
on a treadmill oxygen masks on him and
he was the one who's trying to figure
out how they breathe and they notice
that he has him running and they're not
breathing and that led him to propose
that there was a constraint that the
competing demands of locomotion of
running and breathing were working
against one another and that the mammals
and the arcus or succeeded by bending up
and down and being able to gallop and
were they in train their breath cycles
and their step cycles so of each staff
you have a
run of the lungs fill and Express the
air in them and you say wait a minute Li
crocodiles
you know galloping all I do is lay
around and work on their tan and in fact
it turns out that is as strangely
modified as a as birds are from the
ancestral arcus or so are crocodilians
we can see from the detailed anatomy of
their skeletons that they change their
habits of growth and their habits of
behavior once they get back into the
water and become aquatic carnivores
these amphibious predators they did it
180 million years ago nobody's ever been
able to kick them out of that they're
the top and fibulas carnivores but there
can actually be quite agile under the
right circumstances and they can even
get it up Galip given exactly the right
circumstances is a point bar here a
meander you know a river yeah and the
point bars on one of the meanders now it
turns out these guys usually just lay on
the bank and work on their tan and if
you come up and scare them they just
toboggan down into the water to get away
but if they're away from the water
and there is no slope that they can
slide down right if they're too far
they'll just turn it eat you all right
all the subtlety of a train wreck but if
they're close enough to feel they can
get away they can pull all four feet in
the air
giddy up gallop down to the water and
dive in so the behavioral repertoire is
there all right to be able to breathe
while running they also have a very
fancy one we've known forever I think
Frederick the Great wrote a monograph on
the peculiar lungs that birds have we
have this very primitive blind sac that
we draw air into sucks the oxygen out of
it blows off the carbon dioxide and you
exhale it goes in and out of the same
Sacre birds have very fancy lung only
fresh air
across the gas exchange surface the air
then passes into air sacs in the body
and works its way through and passes out
the neck without ever going back over
the gas exchange surface extremely
efficient long but it's only recently
like in the last two or three years is
somebody bothered to look at alligators
have exactly the same kind of lung as
the birds they don't have the air sacs
in it but there's unidirectional flow
where the air goes in one direction
through and out the lungs so it's a
crocodiles have all this very fancy
system in place that they don't use
that's the idea they've secondarily lost
this during the long course of their
evolution well they wanted to like lay
in the water and wait for you know 40
days before wildebeest gets too close
the next big innovation and by
innovation I mean some change in your
evolution some change your Anatomy or
behavior or physiology that enables you
to meet the challenges of existence in a
fundamentally new way and one of those
apart from the ability to breathe while
running the first innovation is to then
go up on your hind legs we these are
called bipeds they stand on their hind
limbs just like we do and as you'll know
when you stand still there's your center
of gravity your legs are on either side
of it and the faster you move the more
your foot Falls have to fall right on
the midline directly below the center of
mass and it's not really bipedal in the
same way as ours in the dinosaurs
because they use their head and neck and
their tail back and forward in side to
side to maintain their balance over
their hind limbs and unlike us we walk
on the flat of our feet the dinosaurs
all walk on the balls of their feet
because that is actually their ankle
right there this is the drumstick going
up and it attaches to the thigh if it
doesn't realize like what an expert in
dinosaur and
me they are and I can bore my family
cross-eyed at the Thanksgiving table and
I've got a turkey in front of me in a
knife but these guys are standing on the
balls of their 3-toed feet and this
marks that they're not just by P but
bipedal cursors they're called
animals who run and very quickly we know
about these because we have Dinosaur
Park here
hardly any bones from dinosaurs I mean
the glaciers came down and swept all
this stuff away but at one time the this
part of North America was smooshed up
against Germany and Scotland and Germany
Scotland got all the skeletons and we
got all the footprints because there
were these lakes where the continents
were breaking apart to create the North
Atlantic Ocean and these lake systems
opened up here in Connecticut and along
the margins of these lakes you can get
the footprints of dinosaurs you can even
see the scales in the bottom of his feet
on the pads of his feet and that they're
walking on the three-toed feet standing
on the balls of their feet another
problem another constraint is that this
is an anesthetized crocodilian and you
can see that the head raises up
passively with no problem but the head
does not go down it bends at the joint
between the backbone and skull but the
neck itself is not flexible going down
as a consequence for anything below the
eyes they have to turn their head
sideways as you can see here is this
kind of behavior led people to think
that crocodilians ate their young but is
actually a mama crocodile
dile she has this pouch beneath their
jaws grab these guys up and puts them in
there and they go to sleep inside her
mouth and she carries them down to the
water and lets him go and they swim
around she calls to him they'll run
together in a group that very elaborate
parental care but that particular
feature had to be overcome once you get
by people you're standing up in the air
and you really have a problem if you
were down at the level of a crocodile
had to turn your head sideways like how
you gonna catch us
little rat trying to get away from you
who or drink for that matter in one of
the next innovation in there is the
development of this s-shaped neck so
that you can pull the head back over the
body to balance when you're standing
still or lean it forward while you're
running and also like drop down to the
water and we can see that neck appear
even the earliest members of a line
headed towards Birds and everybody can
think of birds with that s-shaped necks
not something you can do but it's
something or the crocodilians but all
the birds are past masters it's one of
the first things right after they become
bipedal and run around on the balls of
their feet there again is the ankle
joint the next innovation is the one we
most know birds by is feathers now this
creature is not a bird at all right it's
way outside of bird land but we've
recently found these things getting
really lucky whereas the American West
would in the 1870s was where all the
dinosaurs are being found in the last
few decades it's China where all the
really fantastic fossils have come and
we got really lucky with the lake bed in
China it's next to a volcano that would
blow on a cage and cast all of this ash
into the air that ash would knock
everything out of the sky and off the
ground
till it drop it into lake poison the
water so there's no bacteria in it and
then give you exquisite preservation we
can tell what they ate for dinner you
know in their summer you can see their
livers all this anatomical detail and
these creatures that are covered with
Nadel down that's the down feathers you
have a chick hatches from an egg it's
all fuzzy that's natal down extremely
effective thermo seal something that
holds in heat you go backpacking you
don't bring a hair bag you bring a down
bag wear a down jacket because really
terrific way of keeping in body heat we
can tell by the anatomy the internal
anatomy of their bone
at that very high basal metabolic rate
and the feathers indicate that they were
trying to hold in heat generated by
their own physiology that they were
hot-blooded they had a tuft of feathers
about their wrists and at the end of
their tail I'll totally learn bird-like
but this is not a creature that could
think about flying of course the bird
wing itself has a particular kind of
week it has of course the tuft of tail
feathers and these are the wrist
feathers and it also has this little
feather right here called the owl bola
and it makes a slot on top of the wing
as the air passes over the wing it keeps
them from stalling at lower speeds so
when you're coming down and want to land
you don't want a boom crash at the end
and this little feather an independent
motion of that feather with respect to
all the others is vital to how a bird
flies and note also the shape of these
feathers it's easy to tell birds that
can fly because they're primary feathers
the flight feathers are curved and the
front end is narrow
there's the rakish the barbs in front or
narrow the vane is big and back and
narrow in front but you can visualize
that you've all seen a you know a
primary fat a flight feather from a bird
and this distorts the feather as it goes
through the flight motion it makes all
of them fold together against one
another is the arm comes out locks the
feathers together make a pattern airfoil
as they come down and then they on the
recovery stroke because the back end is
fatter than the front end right because
here the back end you can see is fat the
front and narrow that makes them all
been like venetian blinds so as they
come back up right reduces drag we power
on the downstroke and power on the
upstroke in order to fly but we always
wondered like well how do you get power
on the upstroke it's not like I'll get
up in a tree I'm gonna jump out start to
meet my arms and like before I
the ground I'm gonna live all power on
the upstroke it's like how do we get
there you know and that's been always
one of our big problems to explain but
we also noted that these guys have it's
called a kinematic chain this is
everybody's have to drop back to your
detailed knowledge of dinosaur Anatomy
there's the sternum and the breast where
you would get the breast muscles
there's the wishbone right and here is
the humerus part of where they call it
buffalo wings right and there's this
muscle that's beneath the big pectoral
muscles in the breast called the super
coracoid yes in every other respectable
four-footed animal it's a muscle that
brings the arm down in birds it's
absolutely unique and that the same
muscle raises the arm up rather than
brings it down it does so by passing the
test the same origin as it doesn't you
up here in your chest
but it goes through a notch up here in
the shoulder and attaches just off the
center of the line of this bone in the
arm so it imparts a twist of the arm and
this is what you ever heard of a
kinematic chain if you'd like to take
four popsicle sticks and stick a pin
through each corner if you move one of
the things everybody else has to move in
a stereotyped fashion so that's how
birds you don't have to learn how to fly
all I got to do is beat the biggest
muscles in their body and their arm
automatically goes through a prescribed
down and forward up and back
flight stroke but again how do you
evolve that before you fly there's some
hints here in the anatomy of the hand in
dinosaurs so this is Deinonychus that's
the Velociraptor of Jurassic Park
everybody knows that story right Michael
Crichton came here to the museum and
Deinonychus is a big bad boy but that
names too tough to say and velociraptor
would be one but if I was a very butch
name
and so excited to use Velociraptor for
what is actually Deinonychus but
Deinonychus has these a very
characteristic and this bone in the
wrist integrates these two that's the
thumb and the index finger and here is
Archaeopteryx the earliest flying
dinosaur just to show you how similar
the three-toed hands are in both a Dinah
a bird that I mean thanks with a cat fly
and one that can but here we have not
only the bones that support the
fingernail but an impression of the
fingernail itself we can see it's long
it's sharp its deeply recurved as a
trenchant very sharp margin
it's basically looks like the feet on a
hawk or an owl but it's the hand in all
of these Raptors like Deinonychus and
velociraptor all that stuff is lost when
you get the modern bird and the hand is
just a platform for holding the feathers
basically but it's this bone right here
that you see integrating these two bones
that from this point on dinosaurs can no
longer dribble the basketball so
something that drives me nuts if you go
look at our Deinonychus it was used in
the Jurassic Park movie and they do the
bunny pose like they can't do that
they're like hands are stuck in this
plane and can move rapidly back and
forth during flight birds can flick this
hand like 30 times a second I mean
really whips back and it's back and
forth can't move up and down again it
has a surface that curves at the back in
here so it automatically brings the arms
down forward up and back the flight
stroke but we can now appreciate that
that flight stroke evolves in the
process of seizing and securing prey
here's power on the upstroke grab ahold
of Protoceratops it got pull it back
they fuse the two clavicles together to
make a wishbone stabilize the shoulder
joint the arms are folded up against the
body or beep
- now let your prey know that you're a
lot closer than you appear and you grab
this thing and pull it back so there's
no way you'd look at a bird flying
around today Oh obviously that flight
spoke of all from an animal that seized
insecure prey it was actually a
raptorial organ taken over by the
demands of flight that's what a fossil
record will do for you now I show this
it's famous because of a the mongolian
the Chinese fighting dinosaurs where
that is actually Velociraptor fighting
with Protoceratops that'll show you how
big Protoceratops is relative to human
and they died in combat I've got an arm
in there and his bit broke in the arm
eyeball like they are fighting it out of
dunes slump down on top of them and
cover them my god works on the evolution
of diet said like usually dinner doesn't
kill you and when you get fossils like
this it's not because they ate
Protoceratops but because they were not
supposed to eat Protoceratops you know
that was somebody taking off a bigger
bite and he could chew but it
nonetheless explains a lot about how
they grab prey how they subdued it and
how they avoid getting a hole poked in
them in the process this is the earliest
flying dinosaur discovered it has
exactly the shoulder girdle hands wrists
and everything that you see in
Deinonychus and this is what led John
Ostrom here my illustrious predecessor
down at the museum to begin the dinosaur
Renaissance was by noting that he knew
Archaeopteryx and then finds this
Deinonychus and says look at this here's
an animal but is not flying but has
exactly the same shoulders and hands as
a flying animal so I've got to come up
with one explanation for these two
different animals to account for what
they do without going through all these
details in this
to say that about everything you can
think of that makes birds different and
stand out among the reptiles actually
originates usually for a very different
function down in some fossil dinosaur
that there's hardly anything that's
really completely unique to living birds
alone I think the only thing that really
is is the size of this big sternum here
the strut in the arm and the size of the
shoulder joint because these guys can
not only fly but they can sustain flight
but I can fly from here to here or del
Fuego down in the other ocean like that
some of of living birds but just about
everything else evolved in dinosaurs but
this led me in doing this work to wonder
this has been a matter of debate in my
field for centuries but it like looks so
easy so straightforward what is it we've
been fighting about and this is where we
can elevate this argument of like where
the dinosaurs come from - what is
science and and how does it work and
this is a great example of it because
here we have a Sir Richard Owen founder
of the British Museum of London and the
father of comparative anatomy now he was
an anti evolutionist or at least an anti
Darwinist a spawn chanting Darwinist and
he was the fellow who named the
Dinosauria in 1841 all right he also
described the London specimen of
Archaeopteryx and I love this photo
since I'm an old fart like and he's
standing there he's holding in his hand
the shaft of the five bone of the malla
and this was back in the day when you
sent your young off to out into the
empire to make their name and a famous
anatomist son went to New Zealand found
this hollow bone shaft he hasn't had
send it back to the British Museum and
Sir Richard Owen said there was a giant
flightless bird
living on new zealand that is now
extinct and everybody mocked him was
pontius of kind of Saturday Night Live a
printed version in England at the time
and you've seen the jokes where the
paleontologist gets like one little
piece of bone and then read instructs
this whole animal that's what that joke
came from and he was the butt of it but
by the end of his career they had found
the intact every bone in it dine artists
and you can see his face right there I
told you so you know but what's
interesting about this is he named
Dinosauria there were only three
specimens known two of them really bad I
mean scraps a bone like this nonetheless
even on such paltry data he said that
the dinosaurs were hot-blooded
he stood upright and had advanced lungs
Wow how did he do that and it's a
measure of the cloud he carried in the
scientific field that he could get away
with making such bold claims on such
paltry data but a thing that was was
interesting to me when I looked into
this was that when he said these are the
features that made dinosaurs a special
group among the reptiles he also used
the exact same characteristic to say
that Archaeopteryx was an extinct bird
and again used the same data to say that
the MOA was an extinct flightless bird
but he never like put that together
maybe the reason they all look like one
others because they all had a common
ancestor in his reason for naming
dinosaur has been thought by historians
of science to be hooded richard owens
kala to put one more nail in the
transmutation s coffin because at this
time before Darwin evolution was thought
of as being progressive evolution that
in effect we were all trying to become
white anglo-saxon male Protestants
right that evolution was going someplace
and towards the Victorian male okay and
that was the view of evolution
progressive evolution and so he thought
as a paleontologist the way I can tear
apart this idea of progressive evolution
is to show that in the distant past that
the reptiles had achieved a very lofty
level of evolution and then as he put it
subsequently D evolved into a sorry
swarm of lizards I work on lizards I
take that as a personal affront but he
wanted to argue then that and so you
look at this we says her hot blooded
erect posture had ten complex lungs in a
four chambered heart and like why did he
think those were like such great things
because I had if you're a creationist
and God did it and God made us in her
image right then we'll we're upright so
God must be upright
we have fancy lungs so God must have
fancy lungs we have four chambered heart
so God must have four chambered heart
we're hot blooded so God must be
hot-blooded and so we were more godlike
right so I just have to show that
reptiles it reached the place where they
were more godlike as well and again
subsequently the evolved to a sorry
swarm of lizards so he had a as I like
to tell my students science the method
is utterly objective but people are
scientists and they aren't I was
something to be borne in mind yes young
lady you have a question it's not at the
end and perhaps we can return to it and
then Darwin came along in 1859 and he
argued in essence okay birds and
crocodiles they don't look very much
like one another I'll grant you that
but as you've gone deeper and deeper in
time we're gonna start to find things
that look more like each other than they
do like their living descendants and
just two years after the publication of
origin but a being find Archaeopteryx
lithographic a--
the teeth and long bony tail of its
ancestors but the feathers and wings of
its descendants
so a prediction he made that is tested
by a subsequent discovery it sounds like
science doesn't it and 1861 saw the
discovery of Compsognathus and this
creature that would be a guy who was
working on the evolution well the
development of the ankle and hind limbs
in the chicken and he's working on how
does this come together how does it look
so different from other things and he
sees this fossil and sees that gee if
you took a little half hashed chicken
and blew it up to that size it looked
just like that and maybe these extinct
dinosaurs are finding or a connection
between regular reptiles and and the
birds he said it in German most of us
didn't read that in eighteen sixties and
so kind of missed that one but this
question next to the origin of man the
origin of flight the origin of birds is
one of them most serious impediments to
a general acceptance the idea of
evolution probably soy Darwin had to
write a separate book on the Descent of
Man Wright as if somehow you miss that
well we're not animals when did that
happen right but you had to make a
separate pitch on that but when he dealt
with the bird situation because it was
so hard to imagine what's the
intermediate between flying and not
flying right that was a tough one to to
conceptualize but they had found by this
time this creature called Megalosaurus
Buckland I and anybody can recognize
long bones from the Lambs and bones from
the back and we had no problem with
those now this is a creature that is a
Tyrannosaurus Rex ëismí it's a large
theropod dinosaur but these bones the
ilium the pubis and the ischium bones of
the pelvis they don't look anything like
mammals and we thought since we didn't
know anything that got that big
elephants hippos rhinos the first
Megalosaurus was reconstructed like that
like a hippo
this is what Megalosaurus actually looks
like but that was the first
reconstruction of it but this fellow
adawn at at Oxford College he looked at
these bones and he noted that there were
how did he put it or knipfing
peculiarities bird-like features and he
wrote to thomas henry huxley also called
Darwin's bulldog and told him you and
Huxley had just in 1867 published his
big monograph on the evolution of birds
he worked on living Birds okay but
Phillip saw these what he called
oranything peculiarities and thought
that you wrote to him and said next time
you're through Oxford come and look at
the remains of Megalosaurus Huxley drop
by look at the bones and the three
mystery bones from the pelvis nobody
else could identify because he knew what
bird bones look like much well that's
the pubis that's ischium and that's the
ilium I know what that is and then he
puts it
I spent the leisure hours of the winters
of 1867 and 1868 you know seeing our
birds are these dinosaurs were just
discovery the three dinosaurs he knew
about you know somehow connected to two
birds he went before the Geological
Society in London and made his pitch in
fact birds are living dinosaurs this
1869 thomas henry huxley is one of these
polymaths like really sick mean guy to
me we did education in england and ran
the Fisheries Department and wrote
monographs on the evolution of this and
that and was Darwin's bulldog would go
down to the factory floor and give
lectures the people about evolution
really an amazing fellow he came to New
York and sellout crowds for him to speak
there and he came up to the Peabody
Museum because nothing was more central
to the Victorian world than the horse
and Charles Marsh the founder of the
Peabody Museum was mr. horse he had
found horses in the American West you
know living horses have one toe he'd
found the three toe horses and Huxley
came here and on
and made this doodle you know as an
evolutionist you got a one toed horse
now you found the three toed horse you
will eventually find a five-toed horse
prediction of evolution right which he
called yo hippest he wrote it right
there Marsh later went in the field
found that fight old horse and called it
yo hip us all after Huxley we still had
that little doodle up in the museum that
Huxley drew awhile he he came here and
quite a figure of a man this is the
Aldous Huxley and that whole family so
it's not just them the whole bunch of
them were famous creative people and
these are the ilium ischium and pubis
that he was able to identify he got up
and said look birds are I mean these
dinosaurs are intermediate between
regular reptiles and birds of the day
now in the audience it's cool because
you gave your address and it was written
out and in the Linnaean society series
they would publish the text of your talk
but also the questions and answers from
the audience afterwards and Harry C Lee
who would mate later named ornithischian
and sorry she and dinosaurs the two
great groups of dinosaurs and and birds
are up in the Cilicians here Sealy says
couldn't it be the reason that birds
look like dinosaurs is because both of
them ran around on their hind legs but
it's not common ancestry that explains
that similarity but the fact that
they're both independently acquired
bipedal habits just as humans have from
the rest of apes and Huxley said well of
course ads could be true but I can't see
science making progress taking that
point of view and as near as I could
tell like this is the start of the
controversy and I want to show you what
I would call them you could see that
there were complications the first
things they find our little and bipedal
and let's face it look very much like
birds but the next discoveries are by
marsh out in the American West are
brought to source okay that doesn't look
like a hummingbird
and Triceratops you know that doesn't
look like a parrot either right and so
because of those discoveries people
began to doubt the birds or dinosaur
hypothesis and entertain more seriously
the idea that dinosaurs and birds
independently acquired their bipedal
habits we later made discoveries showing
the gigantic four footed sauropods came
from small two footed sauropods and
likewise that the big giant four footed
Triceratops came from two footed
ceratopsians of a earlier times in 1974
Bob Bakker of the Jim and Tammy Faye
Bakker family was a student here at Yale
took John Ostrom CH course and changed
his life utterly and became the great
spokesman he became Ostrom bulldog
really and got out there and and argued
with another Yale student in the mid 70s
for dinosaur monophyly in a new class of
vertebrates here get a lot more
dinosaurs than were available to Huxley
like a lot more including Deinonychus
and stuff and they said listen the birds
are living dinosaurs Alan charge at the
British Museum in London there's always
been that little push pull between us
and them said well you know some
dinosaurs were four footed and some are
two footed so maybe each of the
dinosaurs independently evolved multiple
or you bipedalism multiple times these
are reasonable its course it's always
possible but then it shows you that in a
century's time the argument hasn't moved
one step forward then in the face of
increasing evidence that birds are
dinosaurs they're still saying well in
essence they're saying maybe you're
wrong and since you're scientists like
of course that's what sets science apart
from religion we are wrong we can tell
you what will accept showing that we are
wrong and that's a very different state
John Ostrom then
deinonychus found the the Raptors of
Jurassic Park found a misidentified
Archaeopteryx passim and I went to my
first Society of vertebrate paleontology
of meetings as a young student and saw
John Ostrom and Peter Bell no fur from
Germany come and show the new
Archaeopteryx and the new Deinonychus at
the meeting and that went to where
everybody was into mammals in this
society to what's called the dinosaur
Renaissance to now it's like five days
of dinosaur talks you know mammals get
about 20 minutes and it's like changed
the field utterly by these discoveries
and led to the dinosaur Renaissance I
think that the death knell of the
alternative argument really fell apart
with these Chinese feathered dinosaurs
when you exceed ease exquisitely
preserved creatures with feathers
they're hollowed they're branched and
very obviously feather covered so we
went just from reconstructions of
Tyrannosaurus Shawn emits big scaly and
frightening beasts down there we know
Tyrannosaurus have feathers on them in
fact they're needled that we have baby
Tyrannosaurus from China that are
covered with nail down so this is a
giant fuzzy chick that could bite your
car in half you know it's like a very
different image for us of dinosaurs we
even have some early independent
evolutions of flight but the argument
still goes on this is a book published
by Yale University Press
I was difficult for me to say okay okay
do it I'll hold my nose but it's one of
the three people on the planet who
thinks that birds aren't related to
dinosaurs and he essentially in the same
way that Owen saw that Archaeopteryx who
said this doesn't prove Darwin's theory
you know yeah you know it has teeth and
a long bony tail but those are trivial
features you know it has feathers and
wings and those are the important ones
so it's not an intermediate it's already
a bird and I took my class my vertebrate
paleontology class down to the US
National
when the Chinese government brought over
the first feathered dinosaurs and I
walked in to show them the thing and the
three guys on the planet who I don't
think birds are dinosaurs happened to be
in the room and walked over and well
what about that and they said well look
it's got feathers it must be a bird and
I but it doesn't fly and they said well
so it's secondarily flightless and I
realized there were gonna be no data
that we're ever gonna change these guys
mind and so let me show you what's the
problem here this is from some thinking
by Eliot sober let's take two lines of
em you know how old you are and how wise
you are you know to AK Caesar how far
you run how long you live how much you
eat how fat you get whatever variables
you like alright but and you take
observations right and you observe it
always takes something more than the
observation itself to explain
observations to explain the data so
let's take let's say that this is
Huxley's bipedality evolved wants in the
common ancestor of dinosaurs some
dinosaurs got so fat weight-bearing
overwhelmed every other consideration
they went back on all fours but that
their ancestor was bipedal and that's
conserved in living birds so that's an
explanation that so long it passes
through the observations can be said to
explain the observations but here's
another one let's say you're Seeley and
say oh by pettalia rises twice once in
dinosaurs once and birds
well that explanation passes through all
the data points so it's just as good an
explanation is the straight line through
it
let's go all the way up to Allen Chara
says not only do birds and dinosaurs
evolved bipedality independently each of
the dinosaur groups gets bipedality
independently and so you can see we
haven't really tore to us line but it
passes through all the data points it's
just as good an explanation and that it
counts for the data so why should we
choose one explanation over another
that's at the root of the scientific
enterprise and our hope for progress in
science because we get to Alan fanucci
yeah oh they're already dinosaurs
hummingbirds and they're just
secondarily flightless and this puts us
in a very awkward situation and it's
back into the situation we were about
the time during the scholastic period
when we began to ask questions about the
world that actually weren't covered in
the Bible all right you look how much
lice got my spark plug
what kind of domville syria tack I mean
read Bible all you want like there's no
help right but you had to make decisions
about the world even in the face of no
guidance from the Bible and how should
we make those decisions well there were
two lines of thought one was and this is
represented by the st. Bonaventure so we
know which way the church went on this
one that Bonaventure's beard one
explanation for each phenomenon because
God is everything and so the explanation
among these alternative explanations the
one that is the most complex is the one
that's the most like God and for that
reason the one to be preferred the
William of Occam on the other side said
no God is simplicity itself so the
explanation that is the simplest is the
most like God and the one to be
preferred we later during the natural
theology Fay said nature was complex or
nature was simple in the modern
formulation though we like to say that
there could be as complex as simple as
she likes
but our hypotheses about nature must be
simple they must be simple because
they're the only way we can find out
that we're wrong we take these data
points we take the simplest explanation
we find from datum bets off the line
you're wrong
game over oh you're
your theory for aerodynamics says that
bumblebees can fly obviously something's
wrong with your theory there's not a
problem for the bumblebee he's not
having a problem with flight your
capacity to explain it is that issue and
that's what makes science different from
religion is that our it's the thing that
the public cannot forgive me for and I
don't get that well you know why should
I listen to you about global warming you
told me to brush my teeth this way they
went that way and now you're changed
your mind you know it's like yeah we
respond the data we get more David it
says you were full of it on that one
okay off we go and it's the case that I
would Rashad go to a curator in charge
of vertebrate paleontology curator
burbot salty professor of geology and
geophysics would drop evolution in a
heartbeat if in fact all animals
appeared all over the world
simultaneously and in exactly the same
time but that is not what we see in the
fossil record I forbid certain states of
the world now God is not constrained in
that way God can make it look just like
evolution to give me a job you know so
she feels bad for me yeah or can make it
you know all look like instead of a
branching diagram like this like a
dandelion c-pod each different species
independent in the mind of God you know
so there are no limits there are no way
to show that the proposition that God
did it is wrong and that's why you teach
God in a comparative theology course and
Darwin in a science course there isn't
the culture on the planet doesn't have a
religion I mean that's as serious as it
gets that has to be explained all by
itself right but that is a question that
has to do with humans and how you were
that's why creationism is taught in
another class but not in a science class
as an alternative because it cannot be
rejected it is not science period and
with that let me end thank you for your
patience
I thought this is research going on
going on it's been going so so who was
the guy that that taught my generation
that the big fat cold-blooded guys who
is a group who is in the mark hey
they're right well you can see our
museum was done in in 1936 and the tale
of the dinosaurs like brontosaurus all
dragged on the ground and you can see
where they had to like break the tail to
get it down to the ground
everybody knows birds carry their tail
they don't drag them on the ground we
have a zillion dinosaur footprints no
hail drags in those footprints we know
about those six to sixteen hundreds but
dinosaurs were overgrown reptiles they
just did not see them as birds and so
mistakenly thought they were
cold-blooded dragged their tails that's
right
I mean brontosaurus actually Marsh it's
another thing on the sociology of
science yeah this guy he was fighting
with Edward drinker cope Philadelphia
Academy of Sciences and he named the
same species six different times he even
named the tail into one and then the
front end and it kept digging and saw
that the two connected was actually one
animal but he named a pad a source first
forevermore we called the pad a source
brontosaurus but now we know there are
five species in there and brontosaurus
applies to two of them and Apatosaurus
to the other three yes and so nowadays
we we resurrect we never changed the
name
Saurus on our specimen and now we
actually have an excuse okay good I mean
that we have found adults of other
dinosaurs with feathers on it but you're
right though in it when the little chick
hatches out the first set of feathers it
has is natal down it sheds those off and
gets other generations of feathers as it
gets older that's right you're on your
way we actually have some people over in
the department
Derek Briggs there who is who studies
the chemistry of fossilization and it's
turned out it's all mediated by bacteria
it's a very interesting field but they
look at they can see the feathers on
these things and see the bard that can
see patterns on them and they look at
the shape of the things that give them
color and they can tell which ones are
orange and which ones are red and they
actually can reconstruct that color of
these creatures and know that they were
visually oriented by the way their
brains organized and that they use just
as the Cardinals do today color to
differentiate the species and sexes
find dinosaur DNA yeah there have been
people who have been trying to get the
dinosaur limb bones and dig in there and
see if they can find I would have told
you that this is just impossible I mean
how something gonna make it hundreds of
millions of years a protein right many
protein is a coiled shape you know it
has Anatomy right and squash flat cooked
underneath the earth how would that ever
survive but those Chinese feathered
dinosaurs I've seen import of markers
stuff for things that have a an immune
response which requires you be able to
recognize the shape of the protein right
and have those feathers glow for the
same carrot and that's in a feather
today
and honestly 120 million years no way
but there it is they pour into hair
protein on no reaction
they pearl or mammal scales a little
more reacts and they pour reptile scales
more glowing poor feather and as Boone
lights on and you oh my goodness they're
actually three dimensional shapes or the
proteins in this 120 million year old so
it gives us some hope the first ones
done people took something looks like a
red blood cell out of a thigh bone from
a Tyrannosaur and they sequenced it and
said we have sequence a gene from
tyrannosaurus i think then they put it
on one of those phylogenetic tree and it
came out with mammals in fact next to a
pig so that's probably a bologna
sandwich you know a little like DNA out
there but I think people are closing in
on on this we got a shot at it
exactly so 66 million years ago a rock
the size of Manhattan Island smacked
into the planet 99% of the dinosaur
certainly all the large dinosaurs we
know as this thing hit the planet off
the Yucatan Peninsula we found the
impact crater you can see it from outer
space you know it's large right and it
casts all this ejecta into space and
when that ejecta comes back into the
atmosphere it gives off some like
microwaves and if you're big standing
outside you cook you know if you're out
there for about 20 minutes end of you
but if you're underground or under the
water so the turtles and crocodilians
who are aquatic like they go right
through like nothing happened they come
over like a few where'd everybody go
but everybody who exposed the Sun and
all the dinosaurs go extinct at a
minimum there are three species one like
the ostrich relatives the chicken duck
oeid and the rest of birds so all three
of those were like out there at that
time they seemed to have made it through
and us thank goodness
you know 99% of all the things that have
ever lived are extinct that's where and
frighteningly enough to be a large body
size is a great predictor of extinction
we look at all the dinosaurs and think
oh we're small but think of all the
flies and in fact we're gigantic we're
huge animals and we're decreasing in
diversity last ice age there were five
species of humans in sub-saharan Africa
at the last ice age we were the only
ones who came out so bad sign better be
careful of our environment that's the
kind of question I always get over the
phone you know not sure here you mean
longest or tallest or heaviest when use
all of them I think the supersaurus or
ultra sores are probably the heaviest
weigh as much as a herd of elephants
that they have 17 vertebrae in the neck
each vertebrae is 5 feet long and four
and a half feet tall I tell my students
you are not collecting that when they
run into him out in the field you have
to rent a train to bring him back to New
Haven and I'd have to build a building
just to house the skeleton and I can't
write that big a check sir
yeah the velociraptors head is about
that long so it looked just the same
it's just a much smaller species not
something that would take down a human
as Deinonychus could easily that's a
good one
let me be tricky and say it's the
Falcons who are living on top of the
library here they can do 200 miles an
hour and a stoop but I know that's not
what you really ask to be but there are
long-legged dinosaurs even among the
dinosaurs all of whom were fast and
there these uh ostrich mimic dinosaurs
and now they're in the Jurassic Park
movies and they have beaks you know like
a bird but really long legs and speed is
fundamentally a stride length the bigger
step you take the faster you can run so
a cheetah as you know the fastest mammal
is 22 feet between footfalls like when
it's stretched out there I mean you
could chop the arms off in there with
the torso run 45 miles an hour you know
they're very flexible in their body and
a very long legs
where did most of the divers worldwide
as near as we can tell we find him up in
the Arctic and down on the South Pole
again I think we think there was no ice
on those places for most of Earth's
history and the dinosaur seemed to be
worldwide there everywhere just as the
birds are today the first things were
found and all was Megalosaurus Buckland
I was the first one found in England in
the 1600s by a creature you know
t-shirt race we're going to drop some a
t-shirt we'd like to draw the card out